HONEST TRAILER: The Last Airbender
VOICE
From the once successful director
who turned his own name into box-
office poison...comes the poorly
directed, lazily written, terribly
shot, poorly acted, clumsily
edited, oddly paced, insulting
adaptation of...
VOICE (CONT'D)
The Last Airbender.
In crappily converted 3D!
VOICE (CONT'D)
Prepare for the vibrant world of
Nickelodeon's beloved Avatar to get
M. Night Shat-upon in the worst
cartoon adaptation since Dragonball
Evolution.
VOICE (CONT'D)
Watch as the ethnically diverse
heroes you know and love are
brought to life...as generic white
kids!
VOICE (CONT'D)
And the ethnically diverse
villains...stay ethnically diverse
VOICE (CONT'D)
Wonder in amazement at how a $150
million dollar movie ended up with
some of the worst special effects
ever put to film...
VOICE (CONT'D)
Scenes that weren't lit properly...
And unknown child actors who are
bad even by child actor standards.
They haven't been able to conquer big cities like Ba Sing Se
but they're making plans I'm sure.
So, are you the Avatar?
VOICE (CONT'D)
Ugh. I hope these kids stayed in
school.
VOICE (CONT'D)
Journey across four magical
kingdoms, where a chosen few *sort
of* have the power to bend the
elements to their will
VOICE (CONT'D)
Firebenders who can't catch
anything on fire
VOICE (CONT'D)
Waterbenders who can't get this guy
wet.
Water drops on her brother and he's immediately
dry
VOICE (CONT'D)
And Earthbenders who could just as
easily have picked up this rock and
thrown it.
Six Earth benders throw a single rock
VOICE (CONT'D)
But when the evil firebender Prince
Zuko goes on the warpath.
BRING ME ALL YOUR ELDERLY
VOICE (CONT'D)
Humanity's last hope is a boy who
can master every element, The
Avatar.
VOICE (CONT'D)
Oh man, I wish. No, this pouty one
with all the henna tattoos...
doing his green-belt karate
demonstration.
VOICE (CONT'D)
Join Aang and two unnecessary
sidekicks as they struggle to cram
20 episodes of backstory into one
movie, with techniques like...
VOICE (CONT'D)
Weird introductions.
My name is Katara and I'm the only water
bender
left in the southern water tribe.
VOICE (CONT'D)
Weird compliments.
You are a gifted strategist...Your failure
in the
100-day-seige of Bah Sing Se won't be held
against you
VOICE (CONT'D)
Awkward toasts.
I wanted to thank General Iro and young Prince
Zuko
for dining with us...As you know, the fire
lord has banished
his son the prince and renounced his love
of him.
VOICE (CONT'D)
And a super long Star Wars title
crawl.
VOICE (CONT'D)
You really should just fast-forward
through this part.
VOICE (CONT'D)
And maybe even the whole movie...
Starring...
VOICE (CONT'D)
This girl
This Kid
VOICE (CONT'D)
This other kid
This Dude
VOICE (CONT'D)
Who cast this thing?
Oh the guy from the Daily Show!
VOICE (CONT'D)
And Slumdog Millionare!
The Last Airbender
VOICE (CONT'D)
If you thought this was bad, wait
til you see After Earth
So, is this the worst M. Night Shyamalan movie?
Help us decide
by clicking our new Screen Junkies episode.
VOICE (CONT'D)
"Respect my authoritah!"
"There's always money in the banana stand!"
"Flawless Victory"
"It's clobberin' time!"
"You're tearing me apart, Lisa!"
"Join me and together we can rule the ga"